le sourire est révélateur mc2 fille
semble visiblement satisfait de la
tournure de sa cause
le contre-interrogatoire de nigel wright
est devenu le récit d'une crise que
l'entourage de stephen harper voulait
étouffer le plus rapidement possible
vous vouliez mettre fin au supplice de
la goutte d'eau arrêter l'hémorragie a
lancé l'avocat de mac deux filles
stopper l'agonie public il a même laissé
entendre que le premier ministre avait
réclamé un dénouement dans les plus
brefs délais dans un courriel que son
chef de cabinet n'a pas cru bon de
conserver je savais que le premier
ministre voulait qu'on règle la question
a simplement indiqué le témoin les
courriels déposé en preuve et le
témoignage de nigel wright montre
l'inquiétude du groupe prêt à tout pour
indiquer la crise qui va jusqu'à
contrôler le leadership conservateurs au
sénat pendant qu'on force mc2 fille a
accepté tout un scénario qui lui fait
rembourser des allocations qu'il a
perçus alors qu'il est de plus en plus
convaincus d'y avoir droit cela donnait
lieu à plusieurs échanges tendus ils
s'éloignaient parfois de notre entente
adina joe wright c'est pourquoi je
devait persister d'énormes efforts ont
été faits pour garder les canadiens dans
le noir leur faire croire entre autres
que le sénateur avait payé de sa poche
alors que c'est le parti qui devait
rembourser un scénario didot nobel dont
la moralité est discutable est-ce que
l'utilisation de ces fonds publics a
demandé l'avocat était moral ou éthique
je ne pensais évidemment pas que c'était
mal a répondu nigel wray les témoignages
des joe wright a même suscité une
première réaction de mac deux filles
depuis le début de son procès il a
poussé un soupir d'exaspération
quand ils entendus le témoin un suggéré
que le sénateur avait lui aussi
participé à l'élaboration de tout ce
scénario
et si daniel thibault radio canada
ottawa